أول تجربة ممتعة هي تجربة القميص المبلل ،
خذ قميصًا وضعه
في الحوض ، فقط افعل ذلك جيدًا
واتركه يأخذ وقتًا طويلاً للخروج
للخارج ، لذلك نحن الآن في الخارج حيث
درجة الحرارة حوالي خمسة أدناه
دون برودة الرياح  خذ هذا القميص اللعين
وضعه على الحظيرة وسنعود
في غضون ثلاث دقائق و 49
ثانية وأريد فقط أن أرى كيف تبدو القمصان على
ما يرام ، هذا كل ما تطلبه الأمر
مثل لوح كان عندما تم تجميد قميص
آخر  التجربة الممتعة هي مشاهدة الماء
يتبلور ، فقط خذ القليل من الماء المغلي ،
لذا فأنت بالخارج كل ما تفعله هو
رميها في الهواء ، وآخر
شيء يمكنك فعله هو أن تأخذ مزيجًا من الفقاعات القديمة
من الصيف تنفخ الفقاعة
لتلتقطها  يتجمد ثم شاهد كيف
يمكنك كسره ، لقد كسرته يا رائع